-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's a great crowd.
Welcome.
Well, guys, everyone's excited
about this --
the NFL playoffs
are this weekend.
This is a big deal.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Everyone's watching.
The Eagles are taking on
[ Cheering and Whistling ]
the 49ers
and the Chiefs are
up against the Bengals
[ Cheering and applause ]
for a spot in the Super Bowl.
Right before the game,
each coach is going to be like,
"Guys, remember if we win,
we get to see Rihanna.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright? Come on, that's --"
That's right,
the Chiefs-Bengals game
is a rematch
of last year's championship.
Apparently, the NFL saw
how much people loved "Avatar" 2
and thought,
"We should do a sequel."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, ahead of this weekend's
big games,
I saw some of the players have
actually released statements.
Check this out.
First up,
Eagles quarterback
Jalen Hurts said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Up next, Eagles cornerback
Darius Slay said...
-Whoo!
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Then, Chiefs wide receiver
Mecole Hardman said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then Bengals cornerback
Eli Apple said...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-And, finally,
Chiefs quarterback
Patrick Mahomes said...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Either way,
I can't wait to watch
something exciting this weekend.
Some political news --
this weekend in South Carolina,
former President Trump
is holding
his first campaign rally
as a 2024 presidential
candidate.
But I read that his team
is struggling
to find enough people to attend.
[ Laughter ]
But Trump is smart.
Today, his team announced
that his first 10,000 supporters
to show up
will receive
a free classified document.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I feel like Trump's going
to move his speech
to the parking lot of the Chiefs
game and brag, like --
[ As Trump ]
Wow, what a turnout.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Chiefs versus Bengals --
red hat, orange faces --
[ Laughter and applause ]
it's a win-win.
It's a win-win for me.
[ Cheering ]
You can tell Trump's getting
desperate for people to show up.
He's even premiering a trailer
for the new movie...
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
[ Ohhs ]
Well, last night,
President Biden
gave a speech at the White House
and, instead of showing you
everything he said,
we thought it'd be more fun
to just play a short clip
with absolutely zero context.
[ Laughter ]
With that in mind, it's time for
"President Biden
with no Context."
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Enjoy.
[ Upbeat march plays ]
-Oh, you think I'm kidding.
I'm not.
[ Laughter ]
Especially in the middle
of the night,
when she climbs up
and lays on top of my head.
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Some business news --
following the holiday
travel meltdown,
Southwest Airlines said
that they're now testing
a new software fix.
Perfect, just in time for the
late January travel rush.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, guys, people were talking
about this last night --
an asteroid the size of a truck
made the closest approach
to Earth ever recorded.
That's definitely
the type of news
you want to be told about
after it happens.
[ Laughter ]
When the asteroid
got super close,
Eagles fans were like,
"Not now! Not now!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just wait. We're almost --"
That's right, the asteroid was
super close this morning.
When they saw it on the news,
the Space Force said,
"Wow, we really got to start
checking our email."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some entertainment news --
I saw that '80s singer
Rick Astley
is suing the rapper Yung Gravy
for imitating his voice.
And some of the details
and terms within the lawsuit
are actually
kind of interesting.
At one point, he says that he --
-Ah!
I know where this is going.
Does it say that he's
never gonna give you up?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I was going to say
the lawsuit claims
Yung Gravy deliberately did
an exact imitation
of Rick Astley throughout his
hit song "Betty."
Another detail I found
surprising was that he --
-Here we go!
[ Laughter ]
What'd he say, that he's
never gonna let you down?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I was going to say
that Astley did the --
licensed the song,
the instrumental of the song,
which is not his voice.
Kind of weird,
murky legal territory.
Anyway, that's all.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, well,
I'm sorry for being so,
you know, defensive, Jimmy.
I just assumed that you were
going to use this
as an easy opportunity to,
you know, rickroll me.
[ Laughter ]
-No, of course I wouldn't
rickroll you, Tariq.
I mean --
♪♪
♪ We've known each other ♪
[ Cheering, rhythmic clapping ]
♪ For so long ♪
♪ You know the rules ♪
♪ And so do I, so do I ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ Never gonna give you up ♪
♪ Never gonna let you down ♪
♪ Never gonna turn around
and desert you ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hey, guys, I heard
about a company that's offering
to pay a couple $1,000 to build
IKEA furniture together.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-I don't know
if you've ever tried
to put IKEA furniture together
with your spouse, but,
it ain't worth $1,000,
I'll tell you that much.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, guys, as I mentioned,
this weekend is the
NFL's conference championships.
Whoever wins is going
to the Super Bowl
and Sunday afternoon's game has
the Philadelphia Eagles
facing off against the
San Francisco 49ers.
[ Applause and cheering ]
Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards,
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
during the playoffs.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time
for "Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show Superlatives ♪
-Our first player is
from the Eagles.
It's their backup quarterback...
He was voted...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Wow!
-Next up from the 49ers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
"You better not break
her heart, man!"
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Eagles is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the 49ers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-Next up from the Eagles is...
[ Cheering ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the 49ers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally,
from the 49ers is...
[ Cheering ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go, everybody.
Those knows your "Superlatives."